This is Hidden Brain and I'm Shankar Vedantam reporting from your school cafeteria. Okay, not really. But play along with me for a second and picture a typical scene at an elementary school lunchroom. There are kids holding trays with tata tots and turkey sandwiches, the milk is in those little cardboard cartons. There are long tables that serve not just as a place to sit, but as a kind of marketplace.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，为您从学校食堂进行报道。好吧，其实并不是。不过请配合我一下，想象一下小学午餐室里的典型场景。孩子们拿着托盘，上面有小薯饼和火鸡三明治，牛奶装在那些小纸盒里。那里有长长的桌子，不仅充当坐下吃饭的地方，还像是一个某种交易市场。
Hey, I'll trade you two cookies for a bag of potato chips. One young businessman tries to score a deal while trying not to get ripped off. No, that's a bad trade. Of course, if you want even one of these deals, you have to trade stuff that others want. I was so bummed that I couldn't have anything to trade. Because no one wants, you know, like a Clementine. This is Esther. Hi, I'm Esther Bly.
嘿，我拿两块曲奇跟你换一袋薯片。一个年轻的“商人”试图做成一笔买卖，同时尽量不让自己被坑。不，这笔交易不划算。当然，如果你想谈成哪怕一笔这样的交易，你就必须拿别人想要的东西来交换。我当时超级沮丧，因为我没什么东西可拿来交换。因为根本没人想要那种，你知道的，比如克莱门汀柑橘。这是埃丝特。嗨，我是埃丝特·布莱。
Esther's long since graduated from her elementary school cafeteria days. Growing up, her mom kept the kitchen free from food coloring and high fructose corn syrup. Esther's lunch box was subject to the same rules about healthy food. So I would have snap peas, I would have an orange, sometimes you would be leftovers, and one maybe like gummy snack, but it would only be like health gummy. Of course, Esther craved the processed snacks and cereals that her classmates were eating. Television commercials fueled her desire. One of her favorites was with TrixioGur. It's black and white.
埃丝特离开小学食堂的日子已经很久了。在她的成长过程中，她妈妈的厨房里没有食用色素和高果糖玉米糖浆。埃丝特的饭盒也受到同样的健康食品规则的限制。所以我会有糖豆豌豆，会有橙子，有时会有剩菜，还有一个可能是某种软糖零食，但那也只会是健康软糖。当然，埃丝特渴望同学们在吃的那些加工零食和谷物。电视商业广告助长了她的这种渴望。她最喜欢的广告之一是关于蹦蹦兔（Trix）的。它是黑白的。
Hey, a pack is from home. Whoa, Trixio. Trixio. Rabbit is in five of his costumes. I'm too put on a happy face. When you've got Trixio. And he starts describing all the wonderful fruits that, you know, aren't real, but they actually are real.
嘿，这是从家里带的零食。哇，Trix。Trix。兔子穿着他的五套服装。我得摆出一副快乐的面孔。当你拥有Trix的时候。然后他开始描述所有那些美好的水果，你知道的，它们不是真的，但它们实际上又是真的。
Strawberry banana bash, raspberry rainbow! Uh oh! It's the rabbit! Silly rabbit, tricks are f- As the kid take a bite they start to turn the color and at the very end everything's like technicolor. Rinse color to your world! I actually really like Wizard of Oz growing up so I think subconsciously the black and
草莓香蕉大狂欢，树莓彩虹！哦不！是那只兔子！傻兔子，Trix是— 当孩子们咬上一口时，他们的颜色开始发生变化，而在最后，一切都变成了全彩色。为你的世界增添色彩！我小时候其实非常喜欢《绿野仙踪》，所以我觉得潜意识里那则先是黑白后来变成彩色的广告会一直留在我的记忆中，因为我小时候曾一遍、一遍、一遍又一遍地看《绿野仙踪》。现在，蹦蹦兔谷物食品当然被列入了布莱家的冰箱黑名单，因为它含有BHA防腐剂、人工香料和食用色素。但在早餐时间，埃丝特说她妈妈允许她有一个单独的含糖例外。所以我被鼓励不要吃含糖麦片，除非可能她或我父亲在他们小时候吃过这种麦片。所以这算是一种怀旧的放纵。一种怀旧的放纵。
white ad that then turns to color would stick with me because I'd risk of watching Wizard of Oz over and over and over as a child. Now, Trixio Gert of course was banned from the blive family fridge because it had artificial flavors and food colorings. But at breakfast time Esther says Hamam allowed her one solitary sugary exception. So I was an encourage to have sugary cereals unless possibly her or my father had had them growing up. So it was kind of that nostalgic allowance. Unnostalgic allowance.
今天在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们来探讨这个观点。为什么我们许多人对童年时喜欢的商品有一种特殊的情怀？只有我父母。太美味了。埃丝特的父母让她早餐吃糖霜玉米片（Frosted Flakes）和幸运麦圈（Lucky Charms），因为他们在小时候当孩子时就吃过糖霜玉米片和幸运麦圈。如果你仔细想想，父母都喜欢让他们的孩子体验他们曾经经历过的那些美好事物。这是玛丽·布鲁克斯教授。我在亚利桑那大学的埃勒管理学院工作。我对广告效果的心理学很感兴趣。玛丽说，不仅是含糖麦片的味道和气味将记忆巩固在我们的脑海中。
Today on Hidden Brain, we look at this idea. Why do many of us have a soft spot for products that we enjoyed in childhood? Only my parents. So much delicious. Astro's parents let her have frosted flakes and lucky charms for breakfast because they ate frosted flakes and lucky charms for breakfast when they were kids. If you think about it, parents love to have their kids experience the same wonderful things that they did. This is Professor Mary Brooks. I work at the Elearchology Management. At the University of Arizona. And I'm interested in the psychology of advertising effects. Mary says it isn't just the taste and smell of sugary cereals that cement memories in our
而是那些推销这些产品的广告。对于六七岁的孩子来说，带有诸如幸运小精灵拉ucky和老虎托尼等有趣吉祥物的商业广告会非常具有冲击力。孩子们很容易被那些有趣、听起来不错、朗朗上口且有可爱角色的信息所吸引，因为他们的心智对所有这些东西完全是开放的。他们对一切都敞开心扉。
minds. It's the advertising that sells those products. For a six or seven year old, commercials with fun mascots like Lucky the Leprechaun and Tony the Tiger can be really powerful. Children are vulnerable to messages that are fun and sound good and you can sing and they have fun characters because their minds are just so open to all of that. They're open to everything.
幼儿并不具备怀疑精神。他们听着带有可爱兔子的广告，不会去想：一家价值数十亿美元的公司正试图影响我。当然，在某个特定时间点，这种情况会改变，孩子们开始把商业广告当成商业广告来看待。据推测，就我们的脆弱性或易受影响性而言，你对于这扇窗户何时打开和关闭有一些看法，这扇窗户看起来是怎样的？研究表明——虽然我不太确定自己是否相信这一点——就认知能力而言，这种脆弱性在13岁左右结束，这意味着孩子们理解了什么是广告、它是如何运作的以及他们不应该受到它的影响。你应该进行批判性思考，并且在听到广告的同时，他们也能够对其提出质疑。
Small children are not skeptical. They don't listen to commercials with cute rabbits and think, a multi-billion dollar company is trying to influence me. Of course, at a certain point, this changes and kids start to think of commercials as commercials. Presumably, you have some ideas on when the window opens and closes in terms of our vulnerability or impressionability, what does that window look like? The research says, and I'm not sure I believe it, that the vulnerability ends around 13 in terms of your cognitive ability, meaning children's understanding of what advertising is and how it works and that they should not be open to it. You should be thinking critically and they're able to, at the same time, they're hearing it, question it.
这里有个有趣的问题。那些在我们年幼时听到的信息会怎么样？我们成年后的头脑会去质疑它们吗？为了回答这个问题，玛丽与两位同事进行了合作。斯托尼布鲁克大学的保罗·康奈尔，以及我在这里的一位教授同事，他的名字叫杰斯珀·尼尔森。这三人安排了一系列研究，以观察成年人如何看待麦片产品。我们要做的第一件事是确定，我们可以将人们对某种产品营养价值的看法与他们小时候对该产品的接触联系起来。他们在英国收集了一组受试者，并让他们评估一种名为“可可波普”（Cocoa Pops）的巧克力膨化大米麦片的健康程度。
Here's the interesting question. What happens to those messages that we heard when we were small? Do our grown-up minds question them? To answer that question, Mary teamed up with two colleagues. Paul Connell at Stony Brook University, and one of my professor colleagues here, his name is Jesper Nielsen. And the trio arranged a series of studies to look at how adults viewed serial products. The first thing we wanted to do was to establish that we can tie people's beliefs about the nutritiousness of a product with their exposure to that product when they were children. They gathered a sample of people in the United Kingdom and asked them to rate the healthfulness
对于麦片鉴赏家来说，可可波普不应与美国听众在成长过程中吃过的可可波普（Cocoa Puffs）相混淆。可可波普的吉祥物是一只戴着蓝色棒球帽的微笑猴子。研究中的一些人直到成年后才知道可可波普，而另一些人则是吃着这种麦片长大的，并且在他们很小的时候就看过它的广告。那些人将其评为更有营养。所以除了那些在童年时看过它、对可可猴抱有好感和温暖感的人之外，其他所有人对它的营养价值都有更准确的评价。
of a chocolate puffed rice cereal called cocoa pops. For cereal connoisseurs, cocoa pops are not to be confused with the cocoa pops that American listeners may have grown up eating. The cocoa pops mascot is a smiling monkey wearing a blue baseball cap. Some people in the study only learned about cocoa pops when they were adults, others grew up eating the cereal, and had seen commercials for it when they were small kids. Those people rated as much more nutritious. So everyone else has a more accurate rating of how nutritious this is except for the people who saw it as a child and who have feelings of liking and warmth towards the cocoa monkey.
只有可可波普拥有可可的魔法秘密，所以它看起来非常令人兴奋，而且是最有营养的早餐之一，我宁愿来一碗可可。你注意到那句台词了吗？营养早餐的一部分。麦片广告经常使用这样的语言。现在，如果你是一个持怀疑态度的成年人，你可能会猜到配料中含有可可或棉花糖的麦片并不是你最健康的健康选择。但如果你是个孩子，一份营养早餐听起来相当不错。
Only kebabs kebabs has kebabs magic secrets, so it looks like it's very exciting and one of the nutritious breakfasts, I'd rather have a ball of cocoa. Did you catch that line? Part of a nutritious breakfast. Serial commercials often use language like this. Now if you're a skeptical adult, you might guess that a cereal with cocoa or marshmallows in the ingredients is not your healthiest option. But if you're a kid, a nutritious breakfast sounds pretty good.
那么，当你是个孩子时，你易受影响的大脑犯下的错误，难道不应该由你成年后的大脑来纠正吗？当你是个孩子时，一份营养早餐听起来相当不错。那么，当你还是个孩子时，你那易受影响的大脑犯下的错误，难道不应该由你成年后的大脑来纠正吗？嗯，对我和我的一些同事来说，可怕的事情之一就是成年人并不会去纠正它。他们后来并没有说，你知道的，我小时候有这些记忆，你知道的，它们是错的。我真的应该重新考虑一下。所以在我们后来的研究中，这正是我们所检验的，
So shouldn't your grown-up brain correct for the mistakes of your impressionable brain when you're a kid, a nutritious breakfast sounds pretty good. So shouldn't your grown-up brain correct for the mistakes of your impressionable brain when you were a kid? Well, to me one of the scary things is adults don't correct for it. They don't later on say, you know, I have these memories from when I was a child and you know, they're wrong. I really should rethink that. So in our later studies, that's what we actually checked,
即如果我们通过提醒人们注意健康，或者通过提醒人们注意儿童对广告的脆弱性来帮助他们，如果我们这样做，他们是否会纠正这些偏见？而我们再次发现的是，那些对这些角色怀有这种情感的人并没有对其进行纠正。那么，普通成年人难道不应该能够说，看，我小时候很喜欢这个吉祥物，但我已经不再是小孩子了。
is would people, if we help them, by reminding them of health, for example, or reminding them of children's vulnerability to advertising, that if we were to do that, would they then correct these biases? And what we found, again, is that the people who felt that emotion towards these characters did not correct for it. So, shouldn't the average adults be able to say, look, I like the mascot when I was a child, but I'm not a child anymore.
我现在年纪太大了，不会去相信那些幼稚的东西，所以我应该把它放在一边。我想如果你问大多数成年人，你想表现得像个小孩子吗？他们会说，不。为什么这种影响仍然存在？如果我们想把这些抛在脑后，为什么我们在童年听到的话语的影响会留在我们的脑海里？嗯，你必须真正想要把这些抛在脑后。所以我认为这是一种个体差异。有些人确实会从对他们小时候喜欢的事物的热爱中走出来。
I'm too old now to believe in childish things, so I should just set it aside. I think if you ask most adults, do you want to behave childishly? They will say, no. Why is this effect still persisting? Why does the effects of what we hear in childhood stay in our minds if we want to leave those behind in a way? Well, you'd have to really want to leave those behind. So I think that's an individual difference. It's some people do move away from the love of the things they had as kids.
但如果你仔细想想，父母都喜欢让他们的孩子体验他们曾经经历过的那些美好事物，这就是为什么父母喜欢带孩子去迪士尼，喜欢与他们分享自己曾经拥有的玩具。我认为他们仍然热爱这些东西。还记得埃丝特吗？她注重健康的父母破例为她买了糖霜玉米片，因为他们是伴随着老虎托尼长大的。而且不仅仅是在麦片盒上。
But if you think about it, parents love to have their kids experience the same wonderful things that they did, which is why parents love to take their kids to Disney and they love to share with them the toys that they had. And I think that they still love these things. Remember Esther? Her health-conscious parents made an exception for frosted flakes because they grew up with Tony the Tiger. And not just on the cereal box.
老虎托尼，我奶奶，到现在还留着那个垃圾桶。所以我们有一个非常古老的家乐士垃圾桶，上面有老虎托尼，这是他在60、70年代最早的设计之一。麦片吉祥物似乎拥有令人难以置信的力量。埃丝特跟我们讲了那个一直留在她记忆中的蹦蹦兔广告，但她也记得水果圈（Fruit Loops）的具体广告。是的，我真的很喜欢图肯大嘴鸟（Samson Toucan），因为他会去探索。还有奥利奥麦片。那里有一些跳舞的奥利奥玩偶，这让我想起了flubber广告。她甚至从来没尝过奥利奥麦片，但她对它仍然有一种奇怪的喜爱之情。
Tony the Tiger, my grandma, still kept the trash can. So we have this very old Kellogg trash can with Tony the Tiger, one of his very first designs from the 6070s. Serial mascots appear to have incredible power. Esther told us about the trickseoguard ad that stuck with her, but she also remembers specific ads for fruit loops. Yeah, I really like Santa 2ukan because he would go and explore. And an Oreo cereal. There's these dancing Oreo figures and it reminded me of the flubber ad. She's never even tried the Oreo one, but she still feels a kind of strange
对于孩子们来说，讲故事是一件非常容易做到的事，尤其是当有吉祥物参与时。2016年，部分基于像玛丽·布鲁克斯所进行的这类研究，智利共和国禁止在所有产品包装上使用吉祥物，并开展了一场媒体宣传活动，以教育人们了解更健康的食品。吉祥物已经从各种产品中移除，从薯片到麦片。一些食物还被贴上了黑色的标签，上面写着“高热量”（alto en calorías）或“高糖”（alto en azúcares）等字样。我问玛丽，她认为这会奏效吗？基于我的研究，我会全力支持这项努力。
fondness for it. For kids telling a story, it's very easy to do, especially when you have mascot involvement. In 2016, based in part on research studies like the one Mary Brooks conducted, the country of Chile banned mascots from all product packaging and launched a media campaign to educate people about healthier foods. Masksites have been removed from all sorts of products, from chips to cereals. Some foods also have a black sticker slapped on them with labels like alto and caloreas, high in calories, or alto and azucarides, high in sugar. I asked Mary if she thinks it'll work. Based on my research, I would be fully supportive of that effort.
如果他们坚持了10年而没有效果，好吧，那我们就应该回到原来的状态。但我认为它会起作用。我只是觉得你不会在短期内看到结果，因为这些影响是经过很长时间才积累起来的。玛丽自己也记得她童年时期的商业广告，这些广告在她脑海里停留了几十年。我有一段记忆，我和朋友们一起步行去小学，
If they do it for 10 years and it doesn't work, well, then we should go back to what it is. But I think it will work. I just don't think you're going to see the result for a long time, because these effects build up over a long time. Mary herself remembers commercials from her childhood that have stuck with her for several decades. I have a memory of walking to elementary school with my friends,
唱着温斯顿（Winston）的广告歌。这就是为什么抽温斯顿的人比其他任何过滤嘴香烟都多。当我换成温斯顿，我就再也不会改变，因为我的品味就像一个……我知道我会。温斯顿味道好，就该如此。改抽温斯顿，一改到底。温斯顿味道好，就像一场民事诉讼。这是一个令人不安的画面。小学生们在唱一首赞美抽烟优点的歌。你可能会认为，作为一个社会，我们会决定让我们的孩子接触更少的广告，
singing the Winston Jingle. That's why more people smoke Winston and any other filter cigarette. When I change to Winston, I change for good cause I got good taste like a new I would. Winston tastes good like it should. Change to Winston and change for good cause. Winston tastes good like a civil action. It's a disturbing image. Elementary schoolers singing a song about the virtues of smoking. You might think that as a society, we would decide to expose our children to fewer advertisements,
但事实上，正如加利福尼亚州的一个学区所展示的那样，我们可能正朝着完全相反的方向前进。早在2012年，特温里弗斯联合学区（Twin Rivers Unified School District）就资金短缺。热心赞助人介入并主动提供帮助。但其中有一个小小的附加条件。赞助商想要一些东西作为回报。这里是哥伦比亚大学研究员蒂姆·吴（Tim Wu）。他们想要的正是学生的注意力。因此他们提议，学校可以获得，不是它想要的所有资金，而是巨大的财富，只要它同意让学生接触广告，用广告覆盖储物柜，进行一些课堂广告，以及食堂里的广告。你知道，这是个大趋势的一部分，资金短缺的学校有时会转向他们受限制的受众，也就是他们的学生。
but in fact, as a school district in California shows, we might be going in exactly the opposite direction. Back in 2012, the Twin Rivers Unified School District was strapped for cash. Benefactor stepped in and offered to help. But there was one small catch. The benefactors wanted something in exchange. Here's Columbia University researcher Tim Wu. They wanted nothing less than the attention of the students. So they proposed that the school could have all, not all the money it wants, but great
价值1000万美元的广告业。你知道，2010年代的广告商毫不羞于夸耀他们的力量。我记得一个叫克劳德·霍普金斯（Claude Hopkins）的人吹嘘说，你知道的，我们虽然默默无闻，但我们控制着全美国人们想要什么、做什么。
riches if it only agreed to subject its students to advertising, covering the lockers with ads, some in class advertisements, ads in the cafeteria. And you know it's part of a big trend where schools that are strapped for cash have occasionally turned to their captive audiences, namely their students. ["The Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the
我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，您收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。这里是美国国家公共电台（NPR）。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。大多数人都不喜欢广告。我们在浏览器上安装广告拦截器，用数字录像机（DVR）录下我们最喜欢的节目，这样我们就可以快进跳过商业广告。但尽管我们做出了勇敢的努力，各大公司还是发现了非常有效的方法来吸引我们的注意力，尤其是当我们没有意识到的时候。YouTube的跳过广告按钮有时会消失。
Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the
那个在Instagram上有数百万粉丝的运动员开始发布乳清蛋白粉的折扣码。我们可能会失去自由，真正陷入由于自以为是的自愿选择而带来的束缚中。我们已经探讨了广告如何影响我们的思维。在节目的下一部分，我们将探讨名人、企业家和媒体公司如何劫持我们的注意力，以便向我们展示广告。我们从1800年代初的一个故事开始，当时纽约市的报纸行业十分惨淡。
Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the Caterpillar of the $10 million dollar advertising industry. You know, the advertisers in the 1910s were not shy to boast of their powers. I can remember a man named Cloud Hopkins bragging, you know, we are not known, but we control what people all across America want and do.
《纽约时报》当时还没问世，但有少数其他报纸，《商业日报》、《晨报》和《纽约问询报》，它们通常每份收费6美分，在当时这是一大笔钱。本杰明·戴（Benjamin Day）当时从事报纸印刷工作，他认为这个商业模式需要重新启动。6美分实在是太贵了。他决定创办自己的报纸《纽约太阳报》，并以一美分的价格出售。每个人都认为他疯了，但他知道一些别人不知道的事情。
I'm Shankar Vidantum, and you'll listen to Hidden Brain. This is NPR. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vidantam. Most people don't like ads. We install ad blockers on our browsers and DVR our favorite shows so we can fast forward through the commercials. But despite our valiant efforts, companies have discovered remarkably effective ways to capture our attention, especially when we don't realize it. The YouTube Skip Ad button sometimes vanishes.
他的策略是亚马逊的杰夫·贝佐斯也会赞赏的。1835年8月25日，《纽约太阳报》在头版刊登了一篇题为……的故事，读者们得知南非的一位天文学家制造了一台望远镜，可以看到月球表面的微小细节。在接下来的几周里，《纽约太阳报》发布了一连串的新发现。月球上有峡谷、海洋、森林。该望远镜还发现了一种新形式的生命，一种具有科学名称的生物：蝙蝠人（Vespertilio homo）。
That athlete with a million followers on Instagram starts posting discount codes for way protein powder. We can lose our freedom and become entrapped really by doing what we think are voluntary choices. We've explored how advertisements influence our minds. In the next segment of our show, we explore how celebrities, entrepreneurs, and media companies hijack our attention in order to present us with ads. We begin with a story from the early 1800s when the newspaper business in New York City was bleak.
它看起来像一个长着蝙蝠翅膀的人。报纸是这样描述这个生物的。身高平均四英尺，全身除脸部外都覆盖着短而有光泽的铜色毛发，并长有由薄膜组成、无毛、紧贴背部的翅膀。而且显然有着凶猛的性欲。显然，这家报纸在兜售假新闻。但这只是对我们21世纪的人来说是显而易见的。对于1835年的普通人来说，发现月亮蝙蝠是不可思议的。
The New York Times wasn't around yet, but there were a handful of other papers, the Journal of Commerce, the Morning Courier in New York Inquirer, they typically charged $0.6 a copy, which was a lot of money in those days. Benjamin Day was working in newspaper printing and he thought the business model needed a reboot. $0.6 was way too much. He decided to start his own paper, The New York Sun, and sell it for one cent. Everyone thought he was crazy, but he knew something that they didn't.
对于《纽约太阳报》来说，它将该报的发行量推向了无与伦比的高度。哥伦比亚大学法学教授蒂姆·吴写了一本名为《注意力商人》的书，他在书中回顾了我们的注意力被劫持的种种历史方式。通过以一美分的价格出售报纸，本杰明·戴抢占了市场份额，事实证明，这产生了比新闻纸更有价值的东西。发表这些故事的《纽约太阳报》是第一家完全靠收割人类注意力来运营的报纸，也就是我们所说的广告商业模式。
His strategy was one that Jeff Bezos from Amazon could appreciate. On August 25, 1835, the New York Sun ran a front-page story titled, Reader's Learned that an astronomer and South Africa had built a telescope that could see minute details on the surface of the moon. Over the next few weeks, the sun released a stream of new findings. The moon contained canyons, oceans, forests. The telescope also identified a new form of life, a creature with a scientific name, Vespatilio Homo.
因此，它的利润完全取决于其公信力或任何其他东西，而是取决于它拥有多少可以转售的读者。所以这是一个至关重要的历史时刻，它开始了注意力作为一种可以转售并赚大钱的极其宝贵的东西的商品化。这就是为什么我认为这家报纸会被驱动去报道诸如发现月球生命这样的故事，以便建立发行量。
It looked like a human with bat wings. Here's how the newspaper described the creature. The averaged four feet in height will cover it except on the face with short and glassy copper-colored hair and had wings composed of a thin membrane without hair lying snugly upon their backs. And apparently a ferocious sexual appetite. upon their backs. And apparently a ferocious sexual appetite. Obviously, the paper was peddling fake news. But that's only obvious to us in the 21st century. To the average person in 1835, the discovery of moon bats was incredible.
本杰明·戴的商业模式是一个重大的发现。这种模式在今天依然充满活力。注意力是让从糖果制造商到汽车经销商等所有人兜售商品的燃料。事实上，注意力是如此强大，以至于一旦你拥有了它，你就能让人购买他们甚至不知道自己需要的东西。比如，漱口水。在20世纪20年代，
And for the New York Sun, it carried the paper to unrivaled levels of circulation. Columbia University Law Professor Tim Wu has written a book titled The Attention Martians, where he recounts the history of the many ways our attention has been hijacked. By selling the newspaper for a penny, Benjamin Day captured market share and this turned out to produce something much more valuable than newsprint. The New York Sun, which published these stories, was the first paper to run entirely on the harvesting of human attention, what we also call an advertising business model.
李施德林（Listerine）推出了蒂姆称之为“需求工程”的最早例子之一。这是一个围绕一个不熟悉的词“口臭”（halitosis）建立的广告活动。广告声称，这种可怕的状况会让你变得不受欢迎。是的，好吧，你知道的，在2010年代或2020年代之前，人们并不怎么考虑自己是否有口臭。在那个时代，本质上发明了一种新形式的广告，其目标是制造一种本来不一定存在的诉求。它被视为由专业人士完成的科学过程。
And so its profits entirely depended on its credibility or anything else, but how many readers it had that it could resell. So that was a crucial historic moment that began the commodification of attention as something very valuable that you could resell make a lot of money out of. And that's why I think the paper was driven to stories such as discovering life on the moon so it could build a circulation.
并且是支持那些否则可能卖不出去的新产品所必需的。漱口水是其中之一，牙膏是另一个，人们不一定非要它们不可。这里的关键在于，你可以利用你某种程度上收获的人类注意力，然后通过设计新的需求将其转化或旋转成黄金。这就是20世纪20年代广告的魔力或科学，让人们想要他们原本不想要的东西。所以，蒂姆，据我了解，由于这场广告活动，李施德林的销售额从11.5万美元增长到了800万美元以上。是的，没错。2010年代，特别是2020年代，有大量的例子证明
Benjamin Day's business model was a profound discovery. That model is alive and well today. Attention is the fuel that allows everyone from candy makers to car dealers to sell their wares. In fact, attention is so powerful that once you have it, you can get people to buy things they didn't even know they needed. Like for example, Maltwash. In the 1920s,
需求工程发挥了作用。坦率地说，这就是所谓的广告业增长的动力，在此之前，广告业实际上一直是一个边缘产业。以李施德林为例，它以前曾用于不明确的用途。它曾是一种消毒剂。它曾被作为清洗地板的东西出售。但它作为一种漱口水被发明出来
Lisstrein came up with one of the first examples of something Tim calls, demand engineering. It was an advertising campaign built around an unfamiliar word, halitosis. This dreaded condition, the ad claimed, makes you unpopular. Yeah, well, you know, I don't think people thought much about whether they had bad breath or not before the 1910s or 1920s. In that era, new form of advertising was essentially invented, the goal of which was to engineer a demand that did not already necessarily exist. It was seen as a scientific process done by professionals.
以清除、治疗口臭，是其成功的关键。20世纪20年代的注意力商人发现，他们不仅可以创造新的规范，还可以打破旧的规范。最有效的活动之一就是打破女性吸烟的禁忌。女性在公共场合吸烟，甚至根本吸烟，被认为是不体面的禁忌。烟草行业，特别是幸运罢工（Lucky Strike），从两个方向对此发起了攻势。一是试图将香烟打造成女性独立的象征，并与女性选举权运动联合品牌。他们发明了“自由火炬”（torches of freedom）这个词来指代香烟，以表明女性掌握着自己的命运。
And necessary to support new products that might otherwise not sell. Mouthwash being one of them, a toothpaste being another, people didn't necessarily want them. The key there is that you could take human attention, which you've harvested to some extent, and then transform it or spin it into gold by engineering new demands. And that was the magic or the science of advertising in the 1920s to make people want things they didn't otherwise want. So Tim, I understand that Listerine sales grew from $115,000 to over $8 million as a result of this advertising campaign. Yeah, that's right. And there are abundant examples from the 19, 10s, particularly in the 1920s
第二种是屡试不爽的广告技巧，即将香烟与减肥联系起来。那个时代的幸运罢工广告描绘了一个极其肥胖的女人，并写道：五年后的你会是这样吗？抽幸运罢工，或者去拿一包幸运罢工而不是糖果。所以他们确实直奔主题，统计数据是惊人的。它们的销量从微乎其微飙升至专门向女性出售的数百万条。所以我认为这是需求工程最成功的例子之一。为了你喜欢的牙齿，点燃一支幸运罢工。重新点亮。点亮时间的火花。
of demand engineering working. That's what powered, frankly, the growth of something called an advertising industry, which before had really been a marginal industry. In Listerine, to take a specific example, had previously been used for unclear purposes. It had been disinfectant. It had been sold as something to clean floors with. But the invention of it as a mouthwash
90年前，你可能通过一种正在风靡美国的新媒介听到了那个幸运罢工的广告歌。广播不仅抓住了人们的注意力，还把他们聚集在了一起。家人聚集在壁炉旁听富兰克林·罗斯福（FDR）讲话。我最直接的关切是执行我在过去做过的大型工作计划的目标。正如《纽约太阳报》在印刷界所做的那样，奥逊·威尔斯（Orson Welles）在广播界也做到了。水星剧院（Mercury Theater）播放了这些广播节目，由奥逊·威尔斯主持。
to clear, to cure bad breath, was the key to its success. The attention merchants of the 1920s discovered that they could not only create new norms, but they could undo old ones. One of the most effective campaigns was to undermine the taboo could undo old ones. One of the most effective campaigns was to undermine the taboo against women smoking. It was considered unseemly taboo for a woman to smoke in public, or even to smoke at all. And the tobacco industry, particularly Lockheed Stryk, took aim in that in two directions. One was to try to brand cigarettes as a symbol of women's independence, and co-branded with the suffrage movement. They invented this phrase, a torches of freedom to refer to the cigarette to show
我们现在知道，在20世纪初……这为注意力商人开辟了新的途径。广告商开始赞助节目，并经常将公司和产品的名称滑入节目中。试试Rinse。我知道你会加入庞大的女性大军，她们在洗涤时哼着歌。现在，全新的、泡沫丰富的Rinse为您带来全新的阿莫萨纳迪秀。广播的社区属性以一种报纸出版商做梦也想不到的方式利用了注意力。你知道的，19世纪、20世纪初有一些关于群体心理学的著作。当时有一种观点，不完全是当代心理学，即人们在大规模地听某些东西时，会抛弃他们的个人身份，成为表现得更像动物的群体的一部分。
that women were in charge of their own destiny. And the second, which is a well-tried advertising technique, was to link cigarettes to weight loss. There's lucky strike advertisements in the era that picture an enormous fat woman and say, is this you in five years? Smoke lucky strikes or a reach for a lucky not for a sweet. So they certainly went right at it and the statistics are dramatic. They went from very little sales to many millions of cartons being sold to women specifically. And so I think it's one of the most successful examples of demand engineering. for the teeth that you like light up a lucky strike. Relight. It's light of time.
而且你知道，在某些方面是完全疯狂的。这就是那种我们有点失去理智的推测。我认为这种观点有一定的支持。我的意思是，如果你曾经参加过体育赛事或政治集会，你会觉得你已经将自己融入了一个群体，但它只是处于那个理论化水平，没有比这更科学的东西了。如果说广播的出现基本上显示了它能让报纸相形见绌，那么在20世纪50年代出现了一种新产品，它迅速证明自己成为了吸引人们注意力的主导方式。
90 years ago, you might have heard that lucky strike jingle through a new medium that was taking America by storm. Radio didn't just capture people's attention, it brought them together. Families gathered around the fireplace to listen to FDR. My most immediate concern is in carrying out the purposes of the great work program that I had done in the past. And what the New York Sun did in print, Orson Welles did on radio. The Mercury Theater installed these broad cats, Orson Welles.
你说注意力商人历史上非同寻常的事情发生在1956年9月9日星期日。是的，这就是我所称的注意力巅峰，也就是埃尔维斯·普雷斯利（Elvis Presley，猫王）出现在《埃德·沙利文秀》（Ed Sullivan Show）上。它创下了从未被超越的收视份额。虽然曾有过更大的观众群体，但观众的份额从未像那天那样庞大。这可能是我一生中获得的最高荣誉。
We know now that in the early years of the 20th century... This opened up new avenues for attention merchants. Advertisers began sponsoring programs and often slipped the names of companies and products into shows. Try Rinsel. I know you'll join the vast army of women who whistle while they wash. And now the new soapy rich Rinsel presents the new Amosanandi show. The communal aspect of radio, Harnessed Attention, in a way that newspaper publishers could only dream of. You know, there were some 19th century, early 20th century writing on the psychology of the crowd. There was the idea, not exactly contemporary psychology, that people listening to things
而且电视，甚至超越了广播，展现出了这种令人难以置信的能力，能够同时吸引整个国家观看相同的信息。回想起来，这真是了不起。想想今天人们是多么的分裂，他们都收听各自的流媒体。整个国家同时观看同一件事，确实是世纪中叶的产物，这是以前从未匹敌过的，也许在某些方面以后也永远不会匹敌。你知道，在广播和电视出现之前的很长一段时间里，如果你想吸引人们的注意力，你实际上必须把它吸引到一个看起来像公共广场的地方。
in mass sort of shed their individual identity and became part of a group which behaved more like an animal. And you know, in some ways was entirely wild. And that was the speculation that we sort of lost it. I think there's some support for that view. I mean, if you've ever been at a sports event or a political rally and you feel you have submerged yourself into a group, but it was at that level of theorizing, nothing more scientific than that. If radio came along and essentially showed that it could put newspapers to shame, a new product emerged in the 1950s and it quickly proved that it became the dominant way to capture
当然，随着广播和电视的出现，就注意力商人而言，你拥有了一种即使在人们自己家中也能向他们推销东西的能力。因此，家变成了一个占领这片巨大的精神空间的机会，如果你愿意的话，这就是全民族的注意力。是的，我认为这是一个非常重大的发展。
people's attention. You say that something extraordinary in the history of the attention merchants happened on Sunday, September 9th, 1956. Yes, and that is what I labeled peak attention, otherwise known as Elvis Presley appearing on the Ed Sullivan show. Which registered an audience share which has never been been rivaled. They've been larger audiences, but the share of the audiences never been quite as large as on that day. This is probably the greatest honor that I've ever had in my life.
20世纪20年代的人们认为广播广告进入家庭是人们无法容忍的发展。家是家庭的神圣场所。很难想象你会接受家里的商业玩笑。哦不。加蒂姆（Gadium）。想象一下，你会接受家里的商业玩笑。哦……抓住他……我希望有人发明一种喷射瓶，你可以瞄准它，波特夫人。
And television, even beyond radio, had shown this incredible capacity to capture the entire nation at one time, watching the same information. In retrospect, it's remarkable. Think about today how divided people are, how they all listen to their own streams. The whole nation watching one thing at once is really a product of the mid-century and something that was never equal before and maybe in some ways never equal since. You know, it used to be that for a long time before radio and television that if you wanted
我有下一个最好的东西，宝洁公司的一项新发明。它像有魔力一样吸水。它叫Bounty，这种新纸巾实际上能吸引更多的水。你知道，但它伴随着很多诱人的东西……埃尔维斯·普雷斯利……其他广播节目，比如《我爱露西》，所以……我们陷入了一种情况，美国的所有人都会……煞有介事地在晚饭后坐下来……看……电视，在这个过程中……吸收大量的商业广告……以其最……引人注目的形式，即全声音和全视频。这是一次非凡的转变，几乎以惊人的方式允许商业侵入其中，
people's attention, you actually had to capture it in something that looked like the public square. And of course, with the advent of radio and television, what you have as far as the attention marchions are concerned is an ability to sell things to people even when they're inside their own home. So the home becomes an opportunity to capture this enormous mind space, if you will, this attention of the nation. Yes, I think that's a very significant development.
但正如我所说，它倒下时不是带着大棒，而是带着胡萝卜。当然，在过去的15年里，人们对他们在电视上看到的广告数量感到退缩，为了迎合这种担忧，一种新产品应运而生，这个产品就是遥控器。这个想法是，这个设备将赋予你自由，以避免广告，基本上让你掌控自己的电视观看体验。它做到了吗？嗯，许多人可能不知道的是，正如你所说，遥控器作为一种广告杀手而诞生。
One that people in the 20s thought radio advertisements in the home, no one's going to stand for that. The home is a sacred place for family. It's impossible to imagine that you'll have acceptance of commercial banter in the home. Uh-oh. Gadium. will imagine you'll have acceptance of commercial banter in the home uh... catch him uh... i wish somebody would invent a catch a bottle at squirts where you aim it missus porter
它是由真力时（Zenith）作为解决广告问题的方案发明的。早期版本的遥控器看起来像左轮手枪，一把你可以用来“射杀”广告的枪，基本上就是调低音量或切换频道。它作为服务于个人的产品进行营销。然而，从长远来看，我想我们大多数人都经历过这一点，它并没有完全达到那些目的。相反，它开始促成一种不同类型的行为——“冲浪式换台”（channel surfing），即你坐在那里，
i've got the next best thing a new invention from proctor in gamble it absorbs like magic it's called bounty the new paper towel that actually attract more you know but it came with a lot of sweeteners uh... elvis pressley uh... other radio shows i love lucy and so uh... we reached a situation where everyone in the united states with you
按按钮，按按钮，按按钮，有时一按就是几个小时。所以这就产生了一个悖论：有时旨在解放我们或赋予我们力量的设备，却以完全不同的方式奴役着我们，这主要是因为我们薄弱的自我控制能力。这种缺乏自控力正是几乎每一个注意力商人新发明的核心所在。甚至当人们试图将自己从某种形式的精神控制中解放出来时，
know facefully sit down after dinner uh... watch uh... television and in the course of that uh... absorb massive amount of commercial advertising uh... in its most uh compelling form, namely full sound and full video. And it's remarkable transformations, almost remarkably allowed commerce to intrude in that way,
熟练的商人也会找到新的方法来破坏人们移开视线的能力。他们在这场军备竞赛中最大的胜利之一就是发现了电视体育节目。体育转播的转折点是1958年国家橄榄球联盟（NFL）锦标赛，即由小马队（Colts）和巨人队（Giants）对阵的“史上最伟大比赛”，你知道，这是一场极其精彩的橄榄球比赛，但更重要的是，你知道，橄榄球以前没有被大批观众在电视上观看过，直到那时还没有人完全理解它是多么具有吸引力，事实证明，直到今天它依然如此。
but it fell, as I said, not with a stick, but with a carrot. The last 15 years of course, people are recoiling from the amount of advertising they're seeing on television and a new product emerges to cater to this concern and this product is the remote control. The idea is this device is going to allow you freedom to avoid the advertisements to basically be in charge of your own television watching experience. Did it do that? Well, what many people may not know is that the remote control as you suggested was born as an ad killer.
虽然有些削弱，但体育观众非常忠诚。他们是一群极其宝贵的、也许是最有价值的注意力收割机会，这也是电视在20世纪50年代的发明之一。而且我必须说，作为一个体育迷，在比赛进入两分钟警告时，我发现自己坐在电视前看两分半钟的广告，心里在想，上帝啊，我到底在干什么？但当然，我每个星期天都在继续这样做。我认为这是少数几个能证明50年代的旧模式在流媒体和其他竞争对手的时代依然具有影响力的领域之一。体育是传统广播模式的直布罗陀。正如你所说，我也喜欢体育，我会在看体育比赛时忍受广告，而这对其他任何东西我都做不到，所以我认为你是对的。
It was invented by Zenath as a solution to the problem of advertising. The early versions of the remote control looked like a revolver, a gun that you would shoot out the ad, basically turning down the volume or switching channels. And it was marketed as serving the individual. In the long term, however, and I think most of us have experienced this, I didn't quite have those purposes. It instead began enabling a different kind of behavior, channel surfing, where you sort of sit there
随着电视网络占领了人们越来越大的思维空间，新进入者发现很难竞争。制作引人注目的电视节目成本高昂。1992年，MTV正在寻找一种既能吸引并留住人们的注意力，又不用花太多钱的方法。他们想出的解决方案是……这是真实的故事。真实的故事。七个陌生人。被挑选住在一起。并且生活被录像。为了找出会发生什么。什么？当人们不再礼貌。
and push the button, push the button, push the button, sometimes for hours on end. So there's this paradox that sometimes devices designed to liberate us or empower us and enslaving us in completely different ways, mainly because of our weak powers of self-control. This lack of self-control lies at the very heart of nearly every new invention of the attention merchants. Even as people try to liberate themselves from one form of mind control,
因为你接到了电话。并开始变得真实。真实的世界。聊聊这个想法，这在某种程度上就是我们今天所说的真人秀的发现。是的，不，绝对是。MTV在90年代开始思考，好吧，迈克尔·杰克逊的音乐录影带时代可能正在走向终结，或者像杜兰杜兰乐队（Duran Duran）那样，人们不会再看音乐录影带了。我们需要点别的。他们甚至考虑过转播橄榄球。他们做了一小会儿游戏节目，但随后有人提出这样一个想法：
skilled merchants find new ways to undermine people's ability to look away. One of their biggest victories in this arms race was a discovery of televised sports. And the turning point for sports was the 1958 National Football League Championships, the game of the greatest game ever played between the the cults and the giants and you know it was incredibly exciting football game and but more more to the point you know football had not been watched on TV by large audiences and no one quite understood to that point just how captivating it was and it's proven to this day it is
他们真正需要的是肥皂剧。正如我们已经暗示的那样，他们看了肥皂剧，意识到它们的成本实在太高了。MTV的运营成本很低。除了VJ（视频骑师）之外，他们基本上没有其他成本，VJ的报酬是聚会和一些最低工资。所以他们想出了这样一个主意：把一群业余爱好者或普通人聚集在一起，把他们放在一栋房子里，然后看看会发生什么。房子在苏荷区（Soho）。结果是一个名为《真实世界》（The Real World）的节目。正如你已经暗示的那样，
there's been some weekening but but sports audiences are very loyal. They're an exceptionally valuable, maybe the most valuable attention harvesting opportunity, and this is another of TV's inventions in the 1950s. And I have to say as a sports fan myself, I find myself sitting through two and a half minutes of ads at the two minute warning of a game, asking myself, you know, what in God's name am I doing? But of course, I keep doing that every Sunday. It's one of the few times I think that the old model of the 50 still has its sway in
它是真人秀电视的奠基系列，其底层真正驱动力是削减成本，你知道的，我们需要以低成本制作它的想法。最初的《真实世界》的参与者整个拍摄季只得到了1400美元的报酬。所以，你知道的，成本并不是很高。对参与者提出的论点是，我们付给你的报酬不是美元和美分，
an era of, you know, streaming and other competitors. Sports is the Gibraltar of the traditional broadcast model. As you said, I like sports too and I will sit through ads when I would never do it for anything else, so I think you're right. As the television networks captured an ever larger share of people's mind space, new entrance found it difficult to compete. Producing compelling television was expensive. In 1992, MTV was looking for a way to grab and hold people's attention without spending
而是我们将用注意力和名气来支付你。是的，这在某种程度上是一个天才的发现。一种表达方式是，你可以不用支付巨额薪水（尤其是给知名演员），而是可以让所谓的正常、甚至有点正常的人来做这件事，因为他们认为自己会成为名人，至少能红上一小段时间。成千上万的人采用了这个想法并将其付诸实践。
too much money. The solution they came up with... This is the true story. True story. Seven strangers. Hick to live in a lot. And have the lives taped. To find out what happens. What? When people stop being polite.
你不再需要成为一家大公司才能成为注意力商人。我们桌上和手里的屏幕催生了新一代商人，他们找到了更强大的方法让我们不断回头。这将在休息后揭晓，但首先我们需要一点时间，用我们赞助商的一些信息来将你的思维空间货币化。是的，我们也是注意力商人。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，您收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。这里是美国国家公共电台（NPR）。
Because you get the phone. And start getting real. The real world. Talk about this idea that this isn't some ways the discovery of what today we would call reality television. Yes, no, absolutely. MTV 90s started to think, well, it could be that the era of Michael Jackson's videos are coming to an end or Durand Durand, people aren't going to watch videos anymore. We need something else. They actually thought about broadcasting football. They did a game show for a little while, but then someone had the idea that
因为你拿起电话，开始接触真实的世界。谈到这个想法，这在某种程度上可以说是今天我们所谓的真人秀的雏形。是的，绝对是。20世纪90年代的MTV开始思考，迈克尔·杰克逊或杜兰杜兰乐队音乐录影带的时代可能要结束了，人们不再看MV了。我们需要点别的。他们甚至考虑过转播足球。他们做了一会儿游戏节目，但后来有人提出了一个想法：
what they really needed was a soap opera. And as we already suggested, they looked at soap opera and realized that they were far too expensive. MTV was run on the cheap. They had basically no cost other than the VJs who they paid in parties and some minimal salary. So they had the idea of getting a bunch of amateurs or regular people together, putting them in a house and then just seeing what happened. The house was in Soho. Result was a show called The Real World. And as you already suggested,
他们真正需要的是一部肥皂剧。正如我们之前所暗示的，他们研究了肥皂剧，发现成本实在太高了。MTV的运营成本很低。除了用派对和一点微薄薪水支付的VJ之外，他们基本上没有什么成本。于是他们想出了一个主意：找一群业余爱好者或普通人，把他们安排在一栋房子里，然后看看会发生什么。这栋房子在苏荷区。由此诞生了一档名为《真实世界》的节目。正如你之前所说，
it was a founding series of reality television and driven really at bottom by cast cutting, you know, the idea that we needed to show it on the cheap. The participants in the original Real World were paid $1,400 for the entire set. So, you know, not very expensive. And the argument made to the participants was, we are gonna pay you not in dollars and cents,
它是真人秀的奠基之作，其根本动力其实是削减成本，你知道的，就是我们需要低成本制作节目的想法。最初参与《真实世界》的成员在整个拍摄期间只得到了1400美元的报酬。所以，你知道的，成本非常低。当时对参与者提出的说辞是，我们支付给你的不是美元和硬币，
but we're gonna pay you in attention and fame. Yes, this was the genius discovery in a way. It's one way of putting it is that, you know, as opposed to shelling out for a big salary, especially for a famous actor, you could instead get, you know, so-called normal, somewhat normal people to do it for the idea that they would themselves become celebrities, at least for a little while. Thousands of people have taken this idea and run with it.
而是用注意力和名气来支付。是的，这在某种程度上是一个天才般的发现。换句话说，与支付巨额片酬（尤其是给知名演员）相比，你可以让所谓的普通人（或多或少有点正常的人）来做这件事，给他们的回报是他们自己会成为名人，至少能红一小会儿。成千上万的人接受了这个理念并将其发扬光大。
You don't need to be a large corporation anymore to be an attention merchant. The screens on our desks and in our hands have enabled a new breed of merchants who have found ever more powerful ways to keep us coming back. That's coming up after the break, but first we need a moment to monetize your mind space with some messages from our sponsors. Yes, we are Attention Martians too. I'm Shankar Vidantam and you're listening to Hidden Brain. This is NPR.
你不再需要成为一家大公司就能成为注意力商人。我们桌上和手里的屏幕催生了一类新商人，他们找到了更强大的方法让我们不断回头。广告之后即将播出，但首先我们需要一点时间，用赞助商的信息来将你的思维空间变现。是的，我们也是注意力火星人。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，你收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。这是美国国家公共广播电台。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidantam. Today we're talking with author Tim Wu about his book, The Attention Merchants, the Epic Scramble to Get Inside Our Hits. Attention Merchants are television shows, newspaper articles and podcasts that draw you in and then sell your attention to advertisers. The internet has redefined the notion of what and who an attention merchant can be. You don't need to be a Fortune 500 company or an advertising behemoth. You can be someone like Jonah Peretti.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。今天我们邀请了作家蒂姆·吴，来聊聊他的新书《注意力商人：争夺我们大脑的史诗之战》。注意力商人是指那些吸引你关注，然后将你的注意力卖给广告商的电视节目、报纸文章和播客。互联网重新定义了注意力商人的内涵和外延。你不再需要成为财富500强企业或广告巨头，你也可以是像乔纳·佩雷蒂这样的人。
In 2001, the MIT grad student had an idea. He decided to order some personalized Nike sneakers with the word sweatshop printed on them. Nike didn't really take to that suggestion that they rejected it or some employee did as an inappropriate slang. He wrote back and pointed out that sweatshop wasn't slang that it was in the dictionary and they just canceled the order and he wrote a final email saying, well, you know, could you please send me a picture of the 12-year-old who's making my shoes?
2001年，这位麻省理工学院的研究生萌生了一个想法。他决定订购一双印有“血汗工厂”字样的个性化耐克运动鞋。耐克并不太接受这个建议，他们或者某个员工将其视为不恰当的俚语并拒绝了订单。他回信指出“血汗工厂”不是俚语，而是字典里有的词，而耐克只是取消了订单。于是他发了最后一封电子邮件说：“好吧，你知道的，能请你给我寄一张制造我鞋子的12岁童工的照片吗？”
He also went on to write a blog post about his experience or shared this material, described to me what happened and the turn of events that turned this relatively innocuous private interaction into something that was close to a global phenomenon. Well, Jonah Pertie was, here he was in the early 2000s, and he touched a live wire that no one really understood well, which was the tendency of certain stories. I don't know if it was quite a blog post. I think he just sent an email out, and the email got forwarded, got forwarded, got forwarded, got forwarded, got forwarded until millions of people had seen it or read it. We now call that going viral, but that phrase didn't exist back then.
他还写了一篇博客文章讲述自己的经历，或者分享这些素材，向我描述了事情的经过以及一系列的转折，正是这些转折将这个相对无害的私人互动变成了一场近乎全球性的现象。嗯，乔纳·佩雷蒂当时的情况是，那是2000年代初，他触碰了一根当时没有人真正理解的高压线，那就是某些故事的传播倾向。我不知道这算不算是一篇博客文章，我想他只是发了一封电子邮件，然后这封邮件被转发、转发、转发、转发、转发，直到数百万人都看到或读到了它。我们现在称之为“病毒式传播”，但那个词在当时并不存在。
You know, Jonathan told me he then ended up on the, you know, today's show talking about sweatshops. The thing blew up. And you know, that's something we're kind of more familiar with now, but the time it was a new phenomenon, especially, you know, an unknown person having their email just go viral. And it showed that there was something new and unusual about this medium, the web, and the internet. Now Jonah, of course, was not a one-shot wonder.
你知道的，乔纳告诉我，他后来上了《今日秀》节目谈论血汗工厂。事情彻底火了。你知道的，这在现在是我们比较熟悉的事情，但在当时却是一个新现象，尤其是像一个默默无闻的人发出的电子邮件突然病毒式传播开来。这表明这种媒介——网络和互联网，有着某种新颖且不同寻常的东西。当然，乔纳并不是昙花一现。
He went on to do several other things. In fact, he demonstrated that he had something of a knack for finding things that went viral. Describe to us some of the websites that most of us have visited that are the brainchild of Jonah Peretti. Yeah, so Jonah in some ways did a lot to invent our present. Something about virality fascinated him. I think he just thought that experience with the shoes was so strange and weird and unexpected that, you know, he went back almost like a scientist to see if he could bottle that lightning. He founded two websites.
他后来还做了好几件事。事实上，他表现出了某种寻找病毒式传播内容的诀窍。给我们描述一下我们大多数人都访问过、由乔纳·佩雷蒂一手打造的一些网站吧。是的，所以乔纳在某种程度上为塑造我们的现在做出了很多贡献。某种关于病毒式传播的东西让他着迷。我想他只是觉得那次鞋子的经历太奇怪、太诡异、太出乎意料了，以至于他几乎像个科学家一样回去，看看自己能否把这种闪电般的效应装进瓶子里。他创立了两个网站。
One was the Huffington Post, which he co-founded with other people, including Ariana Huffington, which was designed to use these sort of web techniques to push a more left-leaning form of journalism. And it was a tremendous success, transform journalism, not all in good ways, but did. But he even went further and went to the pure distillation of attention with a site name Buzzfeed Laboratories, now known
一个是《赫芬顿邮报》，他是与其他几个人共同创立的，其中包括阿里安娜·赫芬顿，其旨在利用这些网络技术来推动一种更偏向左翼的新闻形式。这是一个巨大的成功，它改变了新闻业，虽然并非都是朝好的方向发展，但它确实做到了。但他甚至走得更远，创立了纯粹提炼注意力的网站，名为“Buzzfeed实验室”，现在被称为
as Buzzfeed, the only goal of which was the pure harvesting of attention by creating viral stories. And that Buzzfeed has obviously transformed web content today as we know it. I remember some time ago, Tim, I was watching something that was forwarded to me by a friend and it showed a video that Buzzfeed had posted where they had a watermelon sitting on a table and these two people working at Buzzfeed essentially wrapped rubber bands around the watermelon and they kept doing so until they were probably hundreds of rubber bands. Yeah. 6.79.
Buzzfeed，其唯一的目的就是通过创作病毒式传播的故事来纯粹地收割注意力。而Buzzfeed显然改变了我们今天所知的网络内容。蒂姆，我记得不久前，我看到了一段朋友转发给我的视频，视频里Buzzfeed在桌子上放了一个西瓜，这两个在Buzzfeed工作的员工不停地往西瓜上套橡皮筋，他们一直套，直到套了大概几百根橡皮筋。对，6.79。
Oh, I see your person. And the idea was, of course, that at some point, the rubber bands would exert enough power on the watermelon to make the watermelon explode. And you sort of knew this was going to happen, but you didn't quite know when it was going to happen. And people like me sat and watched this video on Fold 4. I don't know how long it was. It might have been even 10 or 12 minutes. And all this was of people was people putting rubber bands on a
哦，我懂你的意思了。当然，这个想法是，在某个时刻，橡皮筋会对西瓜施加足够的压力，使西瓜爆炸。你大概知道这会发生，但你又不太清楚它什么时候会发生。像我这样的人就坐在那里看这个长达4分钟的视频——我不知道它有多长，可能甚至有10或12分钟——而这所有的一切，都只是人们在往一个
water melon. And throughout that process, I found myself asking, why is it that I just simply I'm not able to look away? And in some ways, it is an act of genius to create content like that. Yeah. I buzzfeed laboratories. I think the laboratories, it's an important part of the original name, is they just kept experimenting until they found stuff that, for whatever reason, just grab people and wouldn't let it go. Watermelons with rubber bands, maybe more obvious ones like cat photos, they just people kept coming back.
西瓜上套橡皮筋。在整个过程中，我发现自己在问：为什么我偏偏就是移不开视线呢？在某种程度上，创作这样的内容简直是一种天才之举。是的。Buzzfeed实验室，我认为“实验室”这个词是最初名字中很重要的一个部分，他们只是不断试验，直到找到那些出于某种原因能紧紧抓住人们的眼球、让人欲罢不能的东西。套橡皮筋的西瓜，也许还有更明显的猫咪照片，人们就是会不断回来观看。
And I guess we know more about the human mind as a result of Buzzfeed's experiment on us, although I'm not really sure that we like what we found or at least we found that the things were interested in You know aren't necessarily you know reading Tolstoy or something But are these strange things like the one you mentioned? Let's talk for a moment about Silicon Valley and the work of companies like Google and Twitter and Facebook. They have in some ways become masters not just of capturing our attention, but monitoring where our attention goes and building products that cater to the drift of our attention.
我想通过Buzzfeed对我们的实验，我们对人类思维有了更多的了解，尽管我不太确定我们是否喜欢我们发现的东西，或者至少我们发现我们感兴趣的事情，你知道的，不一定是在阅读托尔斯泰之类的内容，而是像你提到的那些奇怪的东西。让我们花点时间谈谈硅谷以及谷歌、推特和脸书等公司的运作。他们在某种程度上不仅成为了捕捉我们注意力的专家，还成为了监控我们的注意力流向并构建迎合这种注意力漂移的产品的专家。
Talk about these new attention merchants, and in some ways they're enormous power over our lives. Yeah, sure. A big turning point in the history of humanity came at the end of the last century, the last millennia, when Silicon Valley, headed by Google, first really started to get into advertising, and turned all the resources, all the know-how,
谈谈这些新的注意力商人们，以及他们在某种程度上对我们生活的巨大权力。当然可以。人类历史上一个巨大的转折点发生在上一世纪、上一个千年之交，当时以谷歌为首的硅谷真正开始涉足广告业，并将工程学和计算机科学的所有资源、所有诀窍、
all the expertise of engineering and computer science to the art and science of capturing as much attention as possible, getting as much data as possible out of people and reselling it to advertisers. That has been a change with profound consequences. I think many or most of us are hooked on one or more online products, which no more about us than anyone else. And frankly, I like this incredible supercomputer designed to get
所有专业知识都投入到了一门艺术和科学中，那就是尽可能多地捕获注意力，从人们身上获取尽可能多的数据，并将其转售给广告商。这是一个带来深远后果的变革。我认为我们中的许多人或大多数人都沉迷于一个或多个在线产品，它们比任何人都更了解我们。坦白说，我喜欢这种令人难以置信的超级计算机，它旨在从我们身上榨取
as much resellable attention out of us as possible. I think this is something that goes beyond even what television or radio was capable of doing because they know so much more about us. They know so much more about you, your vulnerabilities, your desires, and you know, customized marketing can really work. And it's something we really need to watch in this next decade. Many celebrities have come to understand that attention online translates to money. I was reading a website the other day that was describing the Indian cricket star Virat Kohli who has nearly 17 million Instagram followers
尽可能多可转售的注意力。我认为这甚至超越了电视或广播所能做到的极限，因为它们对我们的了解要多得多。它们对你、你的脆弱面、你的欲望了解得太多太多，而且你知道的，定制营销确实能发挥作用。这是我们在接下来的十年中真正需要密切关注的事情。许多名人已经开始明白，线上的注意力可以转化为金钱。我前几天正在浏览一个网站，上面描述了印度板球明星维拉特·科利，他在Instagram上拥有近1700万粉丝，
and the article said that Virat Kohli makes half a million dollars per Instagram post where he promotes a product. That is just mind-boggling. It does show the commercial value of attention, which is really what my book is all about. And it also speaks to the transformation of celebrity. You know, there was once a point where famous people, say the Queen of England or famous scientists, they sort of tried to stay out of public view. They usually had jobs other than being celebrities, say, I don't know, Einstein was trying to discover things. And their mystery seemed to add to the sense of wonder or fame. That's not our model at all.
文章说维拉特·科利每在Instagram上发布一条宣传产品的帖子就能赚五十万美元。这简直令人匪夷所思。这确实显示了注意力的商业价值，而这正是我的书所探讨的核心。这也说明了名人的转型。你知道的，曾经有一段时间，名人，比如英国女王或著名的科学家，他们某种程度上试图远离公众视线。除了当名人之外，他们通常还有别的工作，比如说，我不知道，爱因斯坦试图去发现事物。而他们的神秘感似乎增添了一种惊奇感或名望。这与我们的模式完全不同。
Celebrities or aspiring celebrities seek to e-cout any minute or second. They can get of our attention and stay there, never go away. And as you suggested, there's commercial reasons to do so that you can frankly make a lot of money not only doing your job, but just by being famous. I think maybe Paris Hilton gets some credit for the theory of just being famous for being famous, sick. Famous for being famous is the phrase. But certainly, celebrity has transformed in our times. It isn't just mega-stars who can monetize their celebrity. Increasingly, micro celebrities, often called influencers, are finding there's real money to be made and harvesting the attention of their friends and followers.
名人或渴望成名的人力求榨取我们注意力的每一分钟、每一秒钟，他们能够得到并留在那里的每一刻，永远不会消失。正如你所暗示的，这样做有商业原因，坦白说，你不单靠做本职工作，仅仅通过出名就能赚到很多钱。我想帕丽斯·希尔顿可能因为“因出名而出名”这一理论而配得上一些赞誉。因出名而出名，就是这个短语。但毫无疑问，我们时代的名人已经发生了转变。不仅是超级巨星能够将他们的名气变现。越来越多的微小名人，通常被称为网红，发现通过收割他们的朋友和粉丝的注意力，可以赚到真金白银。
Hi, I'm Sue Tran. I'm currently an associate creative director. We're finally 29 working in the brand and content space. I also have a micro-large following on Instagram with my Instagram handle Sutran with three Addons. Sutran has about 23,000 followers on Instagram. She joined the site five years ago. Since then, she's built up a following of people interested in food and art around New York City.
嗨，我是苏·陈。我目前是一名副创意总监。我们终于29岁了，在品牌和内容领域工作。我在Instagram上也拥有庞大的微型粉丝群，我的Instagram账号是“Sutran”加上三个A。苏·陈在Instagram上大约有23,000名粉丝。她五年前加入了这个网站。从那时起，她积聚了一批对纽约市的美食和艺术感兴趣的粉丝群。
Scattered among some 1,500 photos are pictures of Yankee candles, portable printers, and most recently, pictures of Sue posing with a Google Pixel smartphone. Google is actually through an influencer agency. Influencer marketing agencies has been growing in the last like one or two years just because people want to monetize influential Instagram and bloggers and all that stuff. So they kind of create a platform to make it easier for influencers to seek out sponsors or for sponsors to seek out them. Su says companies pay influencers based on the number of followers they have. I have a rate of 150.
在约1500张照片中，散落着洋基蜡烛、便携式打印机的照片，而最近的则是苏与谷歌Pixel智能手机合影的照片。谷歌实际上是通过一个网红机构。网红营销机构在过去的一两年里一直在增长，原因很简单，大家想要将具有影响力的Instagram用户和博主等变现。因此，他们建立了一个平台，让网红更容易寻找赞助商，或者让赞助商更容易找到他们。苏说，公司根据网红拥有的粉丝数量来支付报酬。我的费率是150。
There's a homemade quality to Su's sponsored posts. Some of them are obviously a little bit more staged, but I don't think I would ever post anything that I didn't feel like was 100% me. Companies want these messages to feel like authentic recommendations from one friend to another rather than advertising messages directed by a multi-billion dollar company. In one picture, Su poses with her Google phone in front of her building in Brooklyn. In another, she's holding the phone while sitting in a Chinese restaurant. To a friend, it might look like she loves her Google phone. But...
苏的赞助帖子有一种自制的感觉。其中一些显然有点过于刻意摆拍了，但我想我永远不会发布任何我觉得不是100%代表我自己的内容。公司希望这些信息感觉像是朋友之间真诚的推荐，而不是由价值数十亿美元的公司导演的广告信息。在一张照片中，苏拿着她的谷歌手机在布鲁克林的建筑物前摆姿势。在另一张照片中，她坐在中餐馆里拿着手机。对朋友来说，这看起来可能像是她非常喜欢她的谷歌手机。但是……
Don't tell anyone, I'm still on my iPhone. It just is, indicates a sort of a new type of media environment where, as you suggested, many more people can be famous, not in the older, traditional sense of, you know, everyone in America knows your face or everyone in the world knows your face, which was the old criteria for people magazine putting your face on the cover. But that, you know, millions of people or hundreds of thousands of people know who you are, and therefore in some smaller way you were micro or nano-famous When we think of celebrities we think of people most often in movies and on television My name is Donald Trump and I'm the largest real estate developer in New York
别告诉任何人，我其实还在用我的iPhone。这恰恰表明了一种新型的媒体环境，正如你所暗示的那样，更多的人可以成名，这与那种旧的传统意义上的出名不同——你知道的，美国每个人都认识你的脸，或者全世界每个人都认识你的脸，这是《人物》杂志将你的面孔印在封面上的旧标准——而是数百万人或数十万人知道你是谁，因此在某种较小的程度上，你是微型或纳米级知名的。当我们想到名人时，我们最常想到的是电影和电视里的人。我是唐纳德·特朗普，我是纽约最大的房地产开发商。
You have a particular interpretation term of how the apprentice led to Donald Trump's election as president Yes, I think that Donald Trump, through the apprentice, and to some degree other parts of his life, understood deeply the power of capturing and using human attention. Now, on the apprentice, I think he studied the, what it takes to capture an audience, some of these things we talked about, Buzzfeed, the sort of plot twists, the unusual surprising behavior. And I think he has, in his presidency, and during his campaign, sought as his primary directive
对于《学徒》节目如何引领唐纳德·特朗普当选总统，你有一个独特的解读。是的，我认为唐纳德·特朗普通过《学徒》节目，以及在某种程度上他生活中的其他部分，深刻理解了捕获和利用人类注意力的力量。在《学徒》节目中，我认为他研究了吸引观众需要什么，其中一些就是我们讨论过的像Buzzfeed那样的方法，比如剧情反转、不同寻常的惊人行为。我认为他在其总统任期内以及竞选期间，一直将此作为他的首要指令：
to always win the battle for attention. Sometimes even losing or appearing to lose, it doesn't matter, as long as there's a good show, a big fight, and everyone's paying attention to me. In his mind, he thinks he's won. And to some degree, it is truer than any of us would like to admit. At some deep level, there's some genius to it. Understanding that the battle for attention is primary to a lot of other battles. The whole country and to some degree, the world, is reacting to his agenda, his presence, his tweets, everything he does.
永远赢得对注意力的争夺战。有时甚至是失败或显得失败，这都无关紧要，只要有一场好戏、一场大战，每个人都在关注我。在他心目中，他认为自己已经赢了。在某种程度上，这比我们任何愿意承认的都要真实。在某种深层次上，这里面蕴含着某种天才。理解对注意力的争夺是许多其他争夺战的基础。整个国家，甚至在某种程度上整个世界，都在对他的议程、他的存在、他的推特、他所做的一切作出反应。
That's also known as power. Even if people are resisting you, they're still paying attention to you. The mental resources of the entire nation, much of the world, have been devoted to this one figure, Mr. Donald Trump. You say that because Trump is an attention merchant, His biggest vulnerability might not be the risk of impeachment, but the risk that people will eventually get bored of him. Talk about that idea that one of the risks of being an attention merchant is that people will eventually start to tune you out.
这也叫做权力。即使人们在抵抗你，他们仍然在关注你。整个国家乃至世界大部分地区的精神资源，都倾注在这一个人物身上，也就是唐纳德·特朗普先生。你说过，由于特朗普是一个注意力商人，他最大的脆弱点可能不是遭到弹劾的风险，而是人们最终会对他感到厌倦的风险。谈谈那个观点，即作为注意力商人的风险之一，是人们最终会开始不再理睬你。
Yes, I think this happens with all advertising, almost all content, and many celebrities with a few exceptions. is we have some innate tendency to get bored, to get used to things, develop some immunity, even a hit show like I Love Lucy eventually lost its audience. And so much as Donald Trump rose to power on an intentional move, almost running his campaign and presidency as a reality show, I think when people begin getting bored, begin tuning out, you can expect a loss of power. He may fade less in the way of Richard Nixon and more in the way of Paris Hilton.
是的，我认为这发生在所有广告、几乎所有内容以及许多名人身上，极少数例外除外。我们都有某种与生俱来的倾向，会感到厌倦，会对事物习以为常，产生某种免疫力，甚至连像《我爱露西》这样大获成功的节目最终也失去了观众。因此，正如唐纳德·特朗普凭借一次蓄意的举动崛起掌握权力，几乎将他的竞选和总统任期当作真人秀节目来运作一样，我认为当人们开始感到厌倦、开始不再理睬时，你可以预料到权力的丧失。他消逝的方式可能不那么像理查德·尼克松，而更像是帕丽斯·希尔顿。
When you step back and look at this long arc of how attention merchants have captured our attention and monetized it and sold it and found ways to figure out what works and what doesn't work. Are there broad patterns that emerge about human nature and human psychology? Are there lessons to be drawn about how the mind works from the story of the attention merchants? I think there are. So first of all, there's lessons as to how we decide what to pay attention to. It's a mixture of voluntary and involuntary mechanisms.
当你退后一步，审视注意力商人如何捕获我们的注意力、将其变现、售卖并找到弄清楚什么有效、什么无效的方法这一漫长历史轨迹时，关于人性和人类心理，是否存在浮现出的宏大模式？从注意力商人的故事中，可以得出哪些关于思维运作方式的教训？我认为是有的。首先，关于我们如何决定将注意力放在何处，是有教训可循的。这是自主和非自主机制的结合。
The science suggests, and I think the history suggests it's true. So we like to think we control what we pay attention to, but in fact, we can sort of be conditioned or involuntarily attracted to things. If you ever found yourself clicking on Facebook and wondering why did I do that? Or if you ever found yourself startled by an ad and watching it, not sure what got you there, you'll know that it's not fully within our voluntary control. Part of this book is motivated by deep interest in human freedom and Part of this book is motivated by deep interest in human freedom and you know a sense that we can lose our freedom and become entrapped really by doing what we think are voluntary
科学表明，历史也表明这是真的。所以我们喜欢认为我们能控制自己关注什么，但事实上，我们可能会被某种条件反射，或被动地、不由自主地被吸引到某些事物上。如果你曾发现自己点击了脸书，然后纳闷我为什么这么做？或者如果你曾被一则广告吓到并看完了它，却不确定是什么让你停下来的，你就会知道这并不完全在我们自主的控制之下。这本书的一部分动机是对人类自由的深刻关注，
choices. I mean I don't have to read email, I don't have to be writing tweets or something. Nonetheless these voluntary choices in a certain environment, can leave one trapped. Another motivation for this book is the experience, which I'm sure many of listeners will have had, where you go to your computer and you have the idea you're going to write just one email. You sit down and suddenly an hour goes by,
以及一种我们可能会失去自由并真正被我们认为是自主选择的行为所困的感觉。我的意思是，我不必阅读电子邮件，我不必写推特之类的东西。尽管如此，在某种特定环境中，这些自主选择却会让人陷入困境。这本书的另一个动机是那种经历，我确信许多听众都有过这种经历，当你走到电脑前，脑子里想着只写一封电子邮件。你坐下来，突然一个小时就过去了，
maybe two hours. They don't know what happened. This sort of surrender of control over our lives, the loss of control, to me speaks deeply to this challenge of freedom and what it means to be autonomous in our time and have a life where you've sort of, to some degree, chosen what you want to do. These are values that seem to me under threat in our times. So there's been a war for our attention for a very long time.
也许两个小时。他们甚至不知道发生了什么。这种对我们生活的控制权的放弃，对自由控制权的丧失，在我看来，深刻地说明了我们这个时代对自由的挑战，以及在我们的时代拥有自主权意味着什么，意味着过一种在某种程度上由你决定自己想做什么的生活。这些似乎是我们这个时代正受到威胁的价值观。所以，对我们注意力的战争已经持续了很长时间。
At least a century, probably much longer than that. Are we just helpless victims in this war where people are waging this battle for our attention? Is there a way that we can, in some ways, take back this battlefield and own our own minds again? Yeah, this is, as you said, something only a century old, advertising 100 years ago was just getting started. So we're in a relatively new, over the course of human civilization environment, and I think we can adapt, we still have our individuality, and ultimately some choice. Now, the challenge is that we
至少一个世纪，可能比这还要长得多。在这场人们为了争夺我们的注意力而展开的战争中，我们难道只是无助的受害者吗？有没有什么办法，在某种程度上让我们夺回这个战场，重新掌控我们自己的大脑？是的，正如你所说，这只是一个存在了百年的事物，100年前的广告业才刚刚起步。所以，在人类文明的进程中，我们处于一个相对较新的环境中，我认为我们可以适应，我们仍然有我们的独特性，归根结底还有所选择。现在，面临的挑战是，我们
face an industry which has spent a century inventing and developing techniques to get us hooked to harvest as much attention as possible. And they're good at it, but we do have choices. And I think it begins with the idea that attention is a resource that you own it, and that one should be very conscious about how it's being spent. I was motivated writing this book by the work of William James, the philosopher, and he pointed out something very straightforward, which is, you know, at the end of your days, your life will have been what you paid attention to. And so deciding how that vital resource is spent in my view is the key to life, frankly,
面对着一个花了一个世纪来发明和发展技术的行业，这些技术旨在让我们上瘾，以收割尽可能多的注意力。他们很擅长此道，但我们确实有选择。我认为这始于这样一个理念：注意力是一种属于你自己的资源，一个人应该对它是如何被花费的保持高度清醒的意识。我在写这本书时，受到了哲学家威廉·詹姆斯的著作的启发，他指出了一个非常简单直接的道理，那就是，你知道的，在你生命的尽头，你的人生就是你所关注的事物。因此，在我看来，决定如何花费这一宝贵资源是生活的关键，坦率地说，
the key to it, meaning, the key to doing and having a life which you think is meaningful. Tim Wu is a professor at Columbia Law School. He is the author of the attention merchants, the epic scramble to get inside our heads. Tim, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Tim, thank you so much. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Barth Shah and edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Raina Cohen, Jenny Schmidt, Thomas Liu, Laura Quarell and Kimela Vargas Restrepo.
这就是关键所在，这意味着，这是过上你认为有意义的、有价值的生活的关键。蒂姆·吴是哥伦比亚法学院教授。他是《注意力商人：争夺我们大脑的史诗之战》一书的作者。蒂姆，谢谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。蒂姆，非常感谢你。本期《隐藏的大脑》由巴思·沙阿制作，塔拉·博伊尔编辑。我们的团队包括雷娜·科恩、珍妮·施密特、托马斯·刘、劳拉·夸雷尔和基梅拉·瓦尔加斯·雷斯特雷波。
NPR's Vice President for Programming and Audience Development is Anya Grunman. You can find more hidden brain on social media, we're on Facebook and Twitter. Please also be sure to subscribe to our podcast. I'm Shankar Vidantam, see you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
NPR负责节目和受众开发的副总裁是阿尼亚·格鲁曼。你可以在社交媒体上找到更多《隐藏的大脑》，我们在脸书和推特上有账号。也请务必订阅我们的播客。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，下周见。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。